gunfire in the Hills surrounding the
village of yoshovic barely three
kilometers away from where Sunday's
fatal shooting of a police officer in
Northern Kosovo occurred
and at a time of surging tensions
between the Serbian and Kosovo
governments
in an area mostly populated by serbs the
threat of sudden danger lurched in this
part of Northern Kosovo where ethnic
conflicts are never far behind
kosovo's government released these
Stills appearing to be from an aerial
footage that it says shows a group of
around 30 heavily armed men who opened
fire at a police station in the village
of banska
the local Serbian Orthodox Church said
masked men forced their way into the
monastery near bangska in an armored
vehicle
and that the priests and pilgrims had
locked themselves inside the monastery
for their own safety while gunmen moved
about the courtyard kosovo's prime
minister Alvin kurti called it a
terrorist attack propped up by
neighboring Serbia
[Music]
organized crime with political financial
and Logistics support from official
Belgrade is attacking our country in
this battle we Implement and protect the
law we protect citizens without
distinction and independent Kosovo in a
press conference held on Sunday evening
Serbian President Alexander vucic denied
the accusations
tens of local serbs were completely
surrounded by Kosovo police it was
obviously done in coordination with
International forces logistically and in
every other way
Kosovo declared independence from Serbia
in 2008 a move rejected by Belgrade
ethnic serbs in Northern Kosovo have
since been seeking autonomy for their
region
there was violence earlier this year
after ethnic Albanian Mayors were
elected in the largely ethnic Serb area
in which turnout was just 3.5 percent
Sunday's attack comes just days after
the latest set of European Union
mediated talks between Kosovo and Serbia
collapsed
prime minister korti accused the EU
Envoy of taking Serbia's side in the
negotiations the eu's foreign policy
Chief Joseph Bode said curti was not
ready to move forward with setting up an
association of Serb majority
municipalities that would give serbs
more autonomy in kosovo's North a goal
that had been approved a decade ago by
Kosovo under eu-sponsored talks with
Serbia
now this latest attack has threatened to
derail the entire process of normalizing
relations between the two sides
an additional pressure in a region that
has already defied several attempts to
do so
Gallego Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera